hello when to welcome to this video
playing mr. Marple I didn't remember it
all playing him but I have played three
times don't remember it all okay so the
pawns your name Yellin d5 is is good but
he played it he played the relatively
best variation yeah this is now I'm
going to be very comparable to the to
the philidor's with connoisseur west of
course the more tactical ways of playing
this opening are not working really this
is kind of okay it's probably probably
about equal yeah unless why play some
some funky continuations
don't know he wants to go age five it
seems really I don't know what this is
all about to be honest but I mean I'm
not quite sure where he wants to cancel
for example maybe he doesn't want to
cancel this is too mundane or is this
close to punishment mode already he's
got no development taking root da that's
okay but I wonder if you can do
something better okay let's let's keep
it simple keep play like I usually do
not trying to totally punish him
this is not bad quite clearly not so
let's see what his move is not quite
sure what what he's got left now the
night moving the night doesn't feel very
attractive no okay this is the most
normal looking move and the piece that
is not doing anything as my my bishop
only seven this is why I tried to open
this up the knight can also probably be
improved but I mean we're talking about
I mean look at what look at his position
he cannot move any piece really
I'm now threatening to just take only
for play Bishop g5 we should g5 Bishop
g4 and so on it's close to it's not not
it looks wrong but close so if I take
now he wants to take with the night yes
that's going to work Bishop g5 is the
more natural continuation takes Bishop
takes Knight e4 Bishop before heavy farm
yeah I can take on c1 rook evade this is
I can invade he's playing without the
knight on b1 it's funny that he really
doesn't have a square no good square
night b3 maybe okay but now I can just
take right I can take on one d2 and grab
the material okay um very nice
everything is covered no entry squares
for the rook so the King has to go to e7
and now I need to go the knight needs to
go to d6
I'm going to stop this
oh yes too
g5 is also possible I need to attack e
form the knight attack c4 and the bishop
then reroute to c6 so I win the pawn and
the game not really possible to avoid
Bishop g4
let's stop this and then go back d76
waiting thank you I can take what I can
also take this first
mmm yeah there's no reason not to take
it home
[Music]
stop any any sort of breakthrough I mean
not that it works but just makes it easy
'm there was a very odd opening very odd
opening play I mean this is okay for
white I think it's just it's a bit like
a reversed philidor's if white goes back
to c2 which he which she did I think
this is this is probably okay for white
they're still engine already likes my
position but okay it's it's normal but I
don't know what h4 h5 is about if you
just Castle and like play normal they
develop pieces and so on
just now just an engine doesn't even
think it's so great for me but Bishop f1
it gets good Jim so I'm taking a
spectrum then this might supposed to
better here yeah d4 should be three
maybe interesting
so my computer wants me to cast a long
is is a little bit with with those
points being already where they are but
there is no threat
yeah here it got really uncomfortable
I have 93 coming yeah I don't think you
can save yourself if black is playing
well
I know allowed me to take but what do
you play I mean this is the engines
recommendation okay well maybe for
something is that possible just fire
away something something like that
should be pretty strong this comes
here's comes here and so on no it's very
good auntie I just take the material
yeah f4i are suspected that this is good
yeah but okay this is basically
technically winning and if you have a
technically winning position you should
go for it like here you see that if the
pawns before I can just attack them
twice and there is nothing that that you
can really do see six wasn't necessary
but just like I can take next move okay
thanks for watching